okay I have video for you today that is
truly like nothing I have ever seen
before Donald Trump was interviewed on
Fox News and he tried to explain the
genesis of getting a cognitive
assessment and brag about the results
and I have to tell you this interview
performance by Donald Trump only raises
more questions about his cognitive state
you really have to hear this now
remember the context is Sunday during an
interview with Fox News's Chris Wallace
the topic of trumps cognitive test and
cognitive state came up Chris Wallace
pointed out according to a new poll
people are more confident in Joe Biden's
cognitive state than in Donald Trump's
and Donald Trump really reacted very
strangely he told Chris Wallace on
Sunday that he would that Joe Biden
wouldn't do as well as Trump did on a
cognitive test when Wallace pointed out
you know that test is pretty easy it was
like identify a drawing of an elephant
Trump said well the last five questions
are really tough and Trump even said to
Chris Wallace that Wallace himself
wouldn't do super well on the test which
is I mean it's just absolutely insane
so cut to yesterday Trump is interviewed
by Fox News and we've got to go through
a piece by piece and you'll see this is
really something else let's just jump
right in Trump starting out by saying he
sought out a cognitive test in order to
prove his critics wrong he immediately
goes off the rails into these tangents
of free association a sort of verbal ink
blot test so the last time I was at the
hospital probably a year ago a little
less than a year ago I asked the doctor
I said is there some kind of a cognitive
test that I could take because I've been
hearing about it because I want to shut
these people up they make their fake
nose they make up stories I mean like
I'll do an interview with you you I
didn't say you can't ask me about this
you guys I say ask me anything I did one
with Chris Wallace he was nice enough to
say he said I just want to tell the
audience there was no question that saw
it bounce okay and he's a tough cookie
and it was a good interview I liked it I
enjoyed it and it was good but I didn't
say you can only ask this you can only
we have to be sharp if you're in the
office of the presidency we have to be
sure so they were saying all these
different things was going all over
whichever suck none of it's stuck
fortunately but one of the reasons it
didn't is that I took a test I said to
the doctor was dr. Ronnie Jackson I said
is there some kind of a test an acuity
test and he said there actually is and
he named it whatever it might be and it
was 30 or 35 questions the first
questions are very easy the last
questions are much more difficult okay
so let's stop there
Trump says he did this a year or less
than a year ago in January of 2018 was
when we reported that Trump took the
Montreal cognitive assessment and claims
to have scored a perfect score on it so
if Trump is referring to that test as
being less than a year ago that's weird
did he take another test more recently
we don't know but as far as we were told
Trump's last cognitive test was two and
a half years ago Trump says it was
recent like unless more recently than
the last year that's another one of
these questions now he also mentions he
did it with dr. Ronnie Jackson dr.
Ronnie Jackson as far as I recall was
already gone in March or April of 2018
so it would be very weird for Trump to
be saying I took this less than a year
ago with dr. Ronnie Jackson because
Ronnie Jackson was gone at that point in
time it's weird Trump also says that
it's 30 or 35 questions well if it is
the Montreal cognitive assessment it's
out of 30 points it's certainly not 30
questions depending on what you consider
a question it's sort of like 15
different exercises again the last ones
are not difficult but let's continue
because then Trump gets into that and
this is maybe the most interesting part
like a memory question it's like you'll
go person woman man camera TV so they
say could you repeat that so I said yeah
so it's person woman man camera TV now
this is absolutely fascinating Trump
gives examples of the memory part he
says you know you have to remember five
words person woman man camera TV now
what Trump is doing there is he's
grouping or chunking the terms by theme
and he's clearly just looking around and
you know
he was talking to a man there must have
been a woman you know maybe off camera
he says camera TV that actually raises
more questions about Trump's cognitive
state because the way this would
normally be done is with unrelated terms
the examples in the sample tests that we
have and are showing our audience the
example words are face velvet Church
Daisy
red so again the words are not related
and the fact that Trump found that
question difficult and maybe he even got
an easier version right like in other
words if Trump's five words that he was
given were related that is also very
strange that he would find it difficult
so Trump is just picking things around
him that makes it a way easier question
and again it shouldn't be particularly
tough let's continue okay that's very
good if you get it in order you get
extra points if you okay though he's
asking you other questions other
questions and then 10 minutes 15 20
minutes later to say remember the first
question not to first put the tenth
question
give us that again can you do that again
and you go person warming man camera TV
if you get it in order you get extra
points they said nobody gets it or notor
it's actually not that easy but for me
it was easy so here it truly sounds like
Trump is being treated like a difficult
child what a good boy you got the words
not only did you get the words right
Donnie you got them in order here's a
lolli and a sticker to put on your shirt
no one gets them in order Trump says
does does anybody understand how insane
it is that Trump is bragging about this
and he actually keeps going and that's
not an easy question in other words they
ask you to you they give you five names
and you have to repeat them and that's
okay
if you repeat them out of order it's
okay but but you know it's not as good
but then when you go back about 20-25
minutes later and they say go back to
that quite they don't tell you this now
the interviewer despite not really
questioning what Trump is saying visibly
looks shell-shocked by what Donald Trump
is talking about but I'm not giving the
guy credit he could have challenged any
single one of these assertions that he
didn't
and then Trump portrays passing the test
as if he just you know spliced the atom
or something it's stunning you know if
you take this test we may have to reveal
it I said it's alright I mean is it
tough tell me about it never heard of it
and I got a perfect mark and the doctors
were they said very few people can do
that very few people get that you
understand it it's not that easy there
were other questions tougher than what I
just did now there Trump says that there
were even harder questions than
remembering five words there really
aren't I mean what there's this question
where as an example you start with a
hundred and then they tell you count
backwards by seven from a hundred so you
go okay 193 86 79 72 etcetera maybe
that's what Trump is referring to
there's another one which is like named
as many words as you can in a minute
let's start with the letter D and you've
got to go you know dog doofus deprave
dilapidate you know it's a you you get
it so there really aren't more difficult
questions and that's all so weird that
Trump is bringing up and then just one
more clip here but it's not that easy
but as soon as they announced my score
and their test all the stuff went away
about me is he comp remember they talked
about 25th amendment and nonsense and
they said Wow
and even the enemies they don't say that
anymore but they do say it about Joe
Biden and honestly he should take the
test in a way as an obligation to
because you have to be able to show this
country that the person that we're
picking as leader is short now of course
the concerns didn't go away when Trump
took the test in fact taking that test
has raised even more questions and
Trump's commentary on the test has
raised even more questions this is one
of the strangest over all time lines
that we've been in for American public
politics certainly since I've had the
David Pakman show
certainly since I've been following
politics and even really that I can
remember while I was alive this is
outrageous it's outrageous what's going
on and another strange thing is that
Trump now says the reason he sought out
the test was to disprove
claims of cognitive decline he never
said that at the time it's another
inconsistency but it also tells us Trump
clearly is following these narratives
that are appearing primarily on
independent media and I know we've joked
around before about indications that
either Don junior or Donald Trump may
have seen segments of the David Pakman
show I'm not claiming that that's the
case and I've know it's certainly
conceivable but but I have no idea
although I am aware of some aides at the
White House that are certainly aware of
the show but what's clear is even when
these things don't appear on corporate
media and we say you know corporate
media really should be talking about X Y
or Z the cognitive stuff has only
appeared on corporate media in the last
couple of months years ago independent
media was talking about it and it is
very clear that Donald Trump was aware
of it and that also is interesting it's
not just Fox News that is sort of
informing Donald Trump's understanding
and lastly Trump still keeps talking
about these cognitive tests as if
they're kind of like IQ type memory
games rather than just crude screenings
for dementia everything about it is
outrageous and we'll have probably a
poll question about this on our
Instagram page so make sure you are
following us there at David Pakman show
on Instagram and if you happen to pull
up your Instagram app on your phone you
might as well give me a follow you can
check out my urban backyard garden and a
lot of other wacky things I'm David
Pakman on Instagram let me tell you real
quick about one of our sponsors cuts
clothing they offer super quality men's
t-shirts and they're giving you 15% off
when you go to david pakman.com slash
cuts that's see UTS because solid color
t-shirts are a really important staple
in pretty much every guy's wardrobe I
think it's really important not to
overlook the value of having t-shirts
you love wearing t-shirts from cuts
clothing have been a game changer for me
and as a company all they deal with our
men's solid color t-shirts so they
actually put a ton of thought into the
comfort the style the durability of the
t-shirts they make they fit perfectly
they're not scratchy they don't shrink
they don't
fade they don't stretch out over time
like so many other t-shirts they're
really the most comfortable t-shirts
I've owned and they look great this
right here that I'm wearing on YouTube
is the split hem crew neck t-shirt very
soft fits me perfectly it's the ideal
length go take a look at what they offer
and once you have it you are really
going to see and feel the difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing you will see why and
you'll get 15% off when you do it by
going to david pakman.com slash cuts
that's david pakman.com slash c UTS